JOSH OKOGIE AND BRANDON INGRAM.
>> Joel: AND OKOGIE IS IN THE
GAME JUST FOR THAT ASSIGNMENT
NOW, ON BRANDON INGRAM.
GOT TO GET IT IN.
IT WILL GOM TO VALANCIUNAS.
BACK TO INGRAM FOR THE WIN.
YES!
.3 TO PLAY.
>> Antonio: YOU SAW IT HERE.
>> Joel: AT THE BUZZER, THAT
WILL DO IT.
BRANDON KINGRAM, BRANDON
KINGRAM.
WE'RE AT THE PERFECT ANGLE FOR
THIS SHOT.
JOEL MEYERS, THE MOMENT THE BALL
LEFT HIS HANDS, YOU KNEW IT WAS
GOOD.
>> Antonio: I HAD MY HAND IN THE
AIR.
IF YOU SEE ME IN THE BACKGROUND,
MY HAND IS IN THE AIR.
I KNEW IT.
BINGO.
>> Joel: OKOGIE HESITATED JUST A
MOMENT.
>> Antonio: BECAUSE YOU DON'T
WANT TO FOUL.
THE LAST THING YOU WANT TO DO IS
FOUL.
BANG.
LET'S GO HOME.
>> Joel: BRANDON INGRAM WITH THE
GAME WINNER, 33 POINTS, ONLY 6
OF 7 FROM BEYOND THE ARC
TONIGHT.
>> Antonio: I LOVE IT.
THIS IS WHAT STARS DO.
>> Joel: HE'S BACK IN HIS
RHYTHM.